walk into this video playing Duluth
universe this is the word and I no no no
okay but he's playing a sort of double
fianchetto with white hmm ok but he's at
least taking the center not playing the
hippopotamus but it's a bit similar ah
sorry so let's just cover cover the the
center anthem make sure to develop I'm
only sleep ok so how to how to proceed
yeah maybe I can provoke some crisis
here on the queenside taking see form
may be provoking him ya can exactly to
do that yeah interesting this is
interesting it's not playing passively
cannot say that but maybe this one yeah
this could be a good move oh haha
blundering c6 whoops hmm i'm giving away
c6 hmm ok oh maybe cannot take it yeah
this i thought would be excellent for me
how does it covered III even
III is hanging with with complete
disaster and also III hangs had
completely overlooked that c6 was saying
maybe it wasn't a problem but this was
pure luck done hadn't considered that at
all yeah this now looks a very very
problematic just take here take the
three what what's the problem yeah if I
take her it takes on f6 I need to take
with the Queen it bit of a shame and you
to take with the pawn I'm sorry yeah but
what can you do it's a central pawn I
should take it
still this pawn on c6 yeah yeah I am hmm
it's not not clear at all all this I'm
man I the same I can jump right into the
position okay but this is good like a
player that's a Quincy one taking a 30
that's not nice yeah hard to tell what's
going on here so what do know
can I have completely lost the thread
IAM night f2 especially horse especially
dump why would i play that really all
right and you can just take you to no
one I'm not sure know if I have a nice
fish appear and then i define fun still
this bishop on d4 d5 looks like looks
like a dangerous piece ok ruki a to come
yeah this is probably a really bad game
but what can you do
not quite sure where I am where I am i
spoiled that this is completely
completely bonkers now no idea so super
tough position you cannot really give
this Bishop away should be for us also
and it's also weird yeah I cannot give
it away yeah probably probably white can
just play this this greedy move let's uh
let's try to shock him takes Queen takes
I'm on this important diagonal and maybe
just takes you six then check
yeah maybe oopsie five was at least
tricky takes Queen takes rook f2 okay
it's not he's not daring to take it but
what's now here oopsie three ants
probably just might be five what a game
I do then don't understand what's going
on here
hmm come and get to the king somehow
check nope I'm warning you can just can
just move move the king I didn't see
that tending Bishop d8 oops crapping the
Queen but you can take a five
unfortunately check check black one one
second Jack Jack White forfeits on time
whoo okay yeah pretty move helps Wow
yeah this was probably a super crappy
game I didn't understand any of that not
at all I mean so around here I mean
isn't this just grateful black hmm
cancels i took and now this and here i
cannot believe that black shouldn't be
in excellent shape here night e to g
four and then night afterwards much
better yeah yeah this isn't clear this
isn't clear at all
as stupid as it looks but it's it's it's
probably okay for white now the computer
likes black but um it's it's just I have
a terrible structure and I'm losing the
Cystic spawn all the time and this is a
superb on pond yeah I just completely
crazy stuff yeah I computer processor
this wins hmm not quite sure why then
maybe take some just take the strong
bishop yeah why does what is just
winning around here this was I was a
funny shot but she wasn't impressed at
all I hear hear the computer gives this
me leading to me to draw actually mmm
funny i smooth is this great yeah this
is my computer so good at chess they
just calculate all kinds of nonsense and
some of it works here I it seems that
I'm not lost anymore okay here I am lost
they could've taken yet Jill this check
yeah I didn't see the check just the Sun
breaks through check get this really
wrestled him but still this was okay
yeah this is objectively better but I
had to have seconds and I needed to
somehow irritate him and it was at the
entire working k when you blundered this
this piece still against four seconds he
should he should have caused win but he
have London the Queen 27 is actually a
maid okay yeah I needed to to remove all
the time Kenny and somehow it was also
working well yeah complete chaos hope
you enjoyed it it wasn't exactly grey
chess